1973 alors que la france vit dans une
opulence sans souci le choc pétrolier
vient tout bousculer
personne ne sait combien de temps durera
la crise dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons le premier ministre s'adresse
aux français ils se rassurent en mai à
un mot à la bouche tu aspires gaspillage
voeux depuis des années nous vivons dans
un pays où l'énergie est abondante sinon
bon marché il en résulte comme toujours
dans ces cas-là du gaspillage les
gaspillages au gal maintenant il faut
mettre un terme ou pour le chasser des
mesures portent à l'époque limitation de
vitesse sur les routes le fait d'être
limité à 120 alors sur les autoroutes je
trouve ça bien diminution du trafic
aérien
interdiction d'éclairer les vitrines et
plus de programmes télé rien pas
démission après 23 heures on éteint et
tout le monde au lit l'arrêt des
émissions de télévision à 23 heures
c'est parfait c'est parfait elle le
prend avec le sourire mais six ans plus
tard rebelote
1979 de nouveau un choc pétrolier est de
nouveau la chasse au gaspi qui cette
fois ci a un visage c'est un petit
bonhomme qui va avoir la vie dure il
s'appelle gaspi et toute la france va
être mobilisée pour le traquer alors au
delà de ce gadget qui va surtout faire
sourire les enfants il ya une réalité
celle la très sérieuse les pays
occidentaux et en particulier la france
consomme trop d'énergie il faut encore
en économiser gaspille est un jeu avec
un but économiser 3 millions de tonnes
de pétrole d'ici l'année 1985 pour jouer
il suffit de conduire en levant le pied
les prémices de l'éco conduite mais dans
les faits est ce que vous connaissez le
gaspi est ce que vous faites quelque
chose dont je ne fais rien je mets aussi
spot publicitaire le gouvernement use de
tous les moyens pour faire passer le
message stop au gaspi mais en plus de
ces incitations quelques restrictions la
température maximale autorisée va être
abaissé de 20 à 19 degrés des contrôles
auront lieu mais seulement dans les
lieux publics et des administrations pas
au domicile des particuliers seule leur
civisme pourra permettre d'atteindre
l'objectif de 2 millions de tonnes de
pétrole l'économie sur le chauffage des
mesures qui en agace certains qu'on
demande pas aux peuples et de percer sur
la ligue le chef du gouvernement et tous
ceux qui l'entourent une le gaz ne font
pas attention au gaspi cette chasse
nationale au gaspi pendant quelques mois
de l'année 1979 aurait selon le
gouvernement de l'époque permis
d'économiser
225 mille tonnes de pétrole
[Musique]